la commission européenne va plancher sur
une directive sur le devoir de vigilance
des entreprises sa mission s'assurer que
les multinationales et leurs filiales
respectent les droits humains et
l'environnement
elle vise un contrôle sur toute leur
chaîne de production y compris les sous
traitants qui peuvent parfois être
nombreux très lointain à l'abri des
regards et des réglementations
il ne suffit pas de fabriquer de
l'électroménager encore faudrait-il
s'assurer que ce ne sont pas des enfants
qui extraient les métaux aucune forêt ou
un village n'est pas détruit pour cela
et pour remplir ses obligations
les entreprises devront bien entendu
contrôler et surveiller audités changer
de sous traitants et cela coûte cher
sentant le vent venir de nombreuses
sociétés ont dépensé des centaines de
milliers d'euros en lobbying lo ng
corporate europe observatory vient de
produire un rapport sur ces entreprises
qui ont tenté de vider la directive de
sa substance
nous avons finalement mis la main sur
des dizaines de documents de lobbing
interne de la dg justice dont nous
rendons compte pour la première fois ici
qui avec le lobbying auprès du parlement
européen révèle les tactiques les
arguments utilisés par ces entreprises
tant en public qu'en coulisses quelques
exemples croustillant avec business
europe association patronale européenne
qui défend les intérêts d'entreprises
privées de 35 pays auprès de l'union
son président est nul autre que l'ancien
patron du medef pierre gattaz business
europe a écrit à la commission pour
faire part de ses inquiétudes vis-à-vis
de cette directive
pour lui le devoir de vigilance devra
imposer une obligation de moyens mais va
des résultats il propose en toute
simplicité d'exclure le changement
climatique de la directive
c'est vrai que c'est un petit détail les
températures extrêmes la mort des forêts
la montée des eaux
il faudrait inclure dans la directive
seulement le dernier rang des sous
traitants pratique on risque moins d'y
détecter du travail des enfants ou du
travail forcé businesseurope plaide pour
l'apparition d'une clause de sauvegarde
qui leur éviterait des procès au cas où
il aurait mis en place des mesures
volontaires de responsabilité sociétale
des entreprises le
est ce comme cela si ces garde-fous
s'avèrent inefficaces pour prévenir des
entorses aux droits humains ou des
pollutions ils seront intouchables
le principe c'est l'intention qui compte
quant au géant de l'agro chimie bayer
celui là même qui a racheté monsanto il
sponsorise un débat sur le site politico
son pdg donne son avis sur cette
directive
elle devrait de se mêler que de droits
humains c'est vrai ça le climat
l'environnement après tout ce n'est pas
si important pour un fabricant de gm et
de pesticides qui dessine des insectes
on saisit bien l'enjeu et quid d'ayem
autres associations d'entreprises qui
regroupe les intérêts de coca cola
danone masmondet nestlé nike et unilever
il suggère de proposer des mesures
incitatives pour respecter les droits
humains comme si ça ne devait pas être
un prérequis et puis il ne faudrait
soumettre aux risques de procès
seulement les atteinte sévère aux droits
de l'homme et encore pas sur toute la
chaîne de sous traitance en 2020
l'association européenne du cacao elle
aussi est créée la direction générale de
la justice au sein de la commission
européenne ils veulent aussi des clauses
de sauvegarde
tiens tiens cela ne serait-il pas pour
éviter des procès bien sordide comme
celui de huit personnes
ancien enfant esclave qui ont poursuivi
mars monde les nestlé entre autres
compagnies pour avoir contribué à l'
esclavage illégales de milliers
d'enfants dans les fermes du cacao
et oui être tenu responsable d'un délit
qu'on a contribué à provoquer quel
concept subversif total qui à cause de
la loi française est l'objet de deux
plaintes pouce de son côté pour que la
loi européenne soit moins contraignante
que la loi hexagonal et le cabinet de
lobbying dont elle est membre souhaite
que le changement climatique ne soient
pas intégrés aux mesures logique pour un
pétrolier les rédacteurs de la directive
arriveront-ils à tenir le cap face aux
pressions des entreprises
à l'autre bout de la chaîne les victimes
des sous traitants et des dégâts
environnementaux aimerait bien pouvoir
aussi faire du lobbying